[Musique]
aujourd'hui les explorateurs viennent du
moyen-orient les grands courants de
laventure se sont inversés et il est
courant de voir sur le port de marseille
débarqué d'un car-ferry ces nouveaux
rois du pétrole
il n'y a pas que le qatar qia dos des
petits miracles comme elle amène les
sources ont vu se multiplier ces
nouveaux riches
ainsi les émirs abdelaziz et le chèque
jafar accompagnés de leur chauffeur
un passe-partout le pétrodollar billets
qui se reconnaît facilement sa taille et
au vert clair inspiré du billet
américain
[Musique]
tous les intéressent et grâce à leur
fortune ils sont prêts à acquérir les
terres les plus arides pour y apporter
richesse et prospérité qui feint pays de
bade un pays
nous avons voté tout notre a prédit chen
hong diot abords de la mairie de chez
vous le but du jeu comment bien vouloir
nous faire goûter votre pétrole sauvez
willy sur pedro très bon tu vas te faire
gros tu es mon s'opère pétrole bongo
lors d'un voté sous et la premier
meilleur celui-là c'est habib sy
[Musique]
où
oui
[Musique]
le raid mer rouge mer de glace va
s'achever ici pour les émirs du pays de
l'or noir au pays de l'or blanc oxylane
a produit et vendu des dates mais pas
n'importe quelle date les dates
historiques de deraa qu'est ce que c'est
que ça met en avant
je ne me dis pas qu'on pourra juger un
homme n'a rôle à ses traits des
faisselles sa mort
[Musique]
anaïs politique est au dessus de son
camp
tu as
[Musique]